We found evidence for a
gravitational wave background
for the very first time.
But what is
a gravitational wave,
and what on earth is
a gravitational wave background?
So, gravitational waves
are ripples
in the fabric of space time.
And if there is a lot of these
gravitational wave signals,
they can add together
and give you a gravitational
wave background.
So, we believe that supermassive
black hole binary systems
are creating this gravitational
wave background.
So, when galaxies merge,
their central supermassive
black holes should also merge
and when they merge,
they create these gravitational
wave signals.
These are so low frequency
that we can detect them
when they have periods
of about 30 years or
1 nanohertz,
and it takes them
about 25 million years to merge.
That means that there's
a lot of time
for another galaxy merger
to happen,
and another one,
and then there are
so many signals
that they create this
gravitational wave background.
So, this is really important
for us to understand
how the universe works.
Do galaxies merge as often
as we think they do?
Looking to the future,
we're hoping to make maps of the
gravitational wave background
and to also find individual
merging supermassive black holes